قد يبدو هذا وكأنه كلب مزخرف
يقف وسط خمس قطط زينة للهالوين ،
لكن الكلب هو مختبر حقيقي باسم
مافريك ، لقد كان مثل فروزن ، أعني
أنه مثل شخص مثل فروزن في
مكانه ، آدم فلوريس ، مالك مافريك ، يقول
إنه كان الأول
في  فناء منزلهم الأمامي في جنوب تكساس حيث قام آدم
بزوجته وحتى ابنته البالغة من العمر خمس
سنوات بتكسير
مافريك ، يبدو أنك أوقفته مؤقتًا وعلق
على أحدهم مزاحًا آخر أعتقد أن
كلبك مكسور لإجراء إعادة تعيين صعبة
الرجوع إلى دليل المالك
مهلا  تعال إلى
مركبة الصعود من المريخ ، بدا الأمر كما لو أن مافريك كان محاصرًا
في أغنية غلوريا جاينور القديمة
[موسيقى]
، وبعد أكثر من دقيقة من
الشلل تمكن آدم من كسر
التعويذة ، لا بأس يا صاح ،
استيقظ ذيله الجامد أولاً ، أشار أحدهم إلى ما
يعتقده المختبر  إنه مؤشر لذا
عرضنا الفيديو على Justin McGill الذي يولد إشارات
إلى Labs في Hunter's Point kennel
في آيوا كان يشير إلى Maverick أو أنه كان
متحجرًا أو لا بحق الجحيم كان يشير إلى أنه
لم يكن خائفًا من لغة جسده  كان ذيله
متوسطًا ، ولم يكن محشورًا بين
ساقيه ، ولم يكن لديه أي سيطرة على
ذلك ، فهذه مجرد غرائز كاملة
خرج من الباب ورأى ذلك وحبسه
على عكس معامل المؤشر الإنجليزية
، لا تُعرف بمؤشرات جميلة
عندما يكتشفون الفريسة  أوه نعم ، إنه قبيح مثل
الجحيم ، ومع ذلك ، ماذا تقول
للأشخاص الذين يقولون أن المختبرات لا تشير بشكل جيد
إلى الأعلى وترى بيت تربية الكلاب الخاص بي ، فالهدف هو
عدم الاتصال بـ Maverick ،
إنه بخير يا صاح